[موسيقى]
اجلس اياهم انا هم خمسه سته انظار
اللي هو عبد العزيز السويكت يجيب ساعات
على كرتون
وفا طبعا
كان ابو عيسى الضامل يجيب مسابيح وخواتهم
رحمها
هناك
[موسيقى]
ابو حسين لا يزال باقيا هنا في سوق الخميس
بمحافظه القطيف هذا السوق الشعبي الذي
يتجاوز عمره المائه عام انا انا واحد في
السبعين وقالوا من قبلنا ان في 110 سنوات
110 سنوات وممكن اقدم بعض لان هني متعودين
من القدم من اجدادنا من ابوتنا تعودنا على
السوق هذي يعني الاسواق المتجوله نروح
ونبسط هنا منتجات متنوعه واسعار مقبوله
هذا ما يفسر حاله الاقبال الكبيره من
اهالي القطيف على هذا السوق المقتضي
بالبضائع على جميع الاشياء السينما تبحث
عني في مكان في مكان اخر ما تتحصل بس
هالمكان هل تحصل اشياء كثيره منها هذا اجل
للسوق هذا اسبوعيا طبعا
بالاشياء القديمه اللي موجوده في متحفظين
فيها تاريخيا اهالي القطيف امال كبيره
يعلقها الباعه في سوق الخميس على امانه
المنطقه الشرقيه لتحسين اوضاع السوق الذي
يعاني من مشاكل عده العربيه تواصلت مع
بلديه محافظه القطيف التي اوضحت انها
ستعلن قريبا عن خطه لتطوير السوق ومعالجه
السلبيات التي يعاني منها
عبد الرحمن العصيمي من محافظه القطيف
العربيه